بين اجواء الدوحه المتفائله والاجواء
البيت الابيض الحذره كيف تبدو الاجواء حتى
الساعه في
اسرائيل ا الاجواء تبدو غامضه في الحقيقه
سلمى لعده اعتبارات ابرزها ان ان نتنياهو
مازال يؤكد في خطاب في خطاباته على ان
اسرائيل ماضيه في هذه الحرب ويشدد على تلك
الخطوط الحمراء التي لطالما في الفتره
الاخيره رجع واكد عليها وهي تتمثل في عدم
وقف الحرب عدم اطلاق سراح عدد كبير من
الاسرى الفلسطينيين وسحب القوات
الاسرائليه من كامل قطاع غزه لكن في
المقابل مكتب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي قبل
قليل اكد على ان تلبيب تلقت رد حركه
حماس عن طريق الوسيط القط الى المصاد وعلى
ان كل المشاركين في المفاوضات يقومون في
هذه الاثناء بدراسه معمقه لتفاصيل رد حركه
حماس دون الحديث عن اي تفاصيل اخرى بشان
لربما ردت الفعل على الاقل الاولى
لاسرائيل من هذا الرد الذي تسلمته عن طريق
الوسيط القطري من حركه حماس لكن الانقسام
الحاصل الان في الحقيقه سلمى في اسرائيل
يبدو او يعطي اشارات على ان رد اسرائيل
لربما قد يكون صعبا لماذا لان هناك انقسام
كبير نتنياهو ما زال يصر على تلك الشروط
او اللاءات الثلاثه وايضا هناك اليمين
المتطرف
خاصه وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ايتمار
بن كفير الذي وصل الى حد انتقاد الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في عدد من قراراتها ومن
بينها بعدما اشيع بشان حول او حول الضغوط
الامريكيه على اسرائيل من اجل القبول بدنه
انسانيه تمتد لاكثر من اربعه اشهر لكن
هناك ايضا في الجهه المقابله من يطالب هنا
في اسرائيل
بضروره التوصل الى هدنه تفضي في الاخير
الى وقف الحرب واطلاق سراح المحتجزين
والاسرى الاسرائيليين لدى المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في غزه والبالغ عددهم كما نعلم
136 وعلى راسهم زعيم المعارضه لابيد الذي
عاد اليوم من جديد وانتقد سياسات بنيامين
نتنياهو الذي وصف بانه اصبح رهينه في يد
اليمين المتطرف وهنا الحديث عن سموتريتش
وبينغ فير بالدرجه الاولى وقال بان هناك
اطار الان يتشكل في اسرائيل قد يفضي الى
اطلاق سراح الرهائن
وكانت كان في تصريحاته اشارات كثيره
ايجابيه بهذا الخصوص لكن هناك ايضا بيني
جينس الذي كما نعلم هو وزير في كابينيه
الحرب لربما بات موقفه اقرب الى نتنياهو
بضروره مواصله الحرب حتى القضاء على قدرات
حركه حماس لكنه يعود ويؤكد على ضروره
ايجاد اطار في طريق اطلاق المحتجزين
والاسرى الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه